- Thank you so much, Judy, for
such a detailed introduction.
You actually added a lot to my
presentation, a lot of details
that I want talk, so that's
really great, memorable.
That's usual.
I don't know how you
can do this every time.
Thanks Dean Cohen, Judy, Sharon,
Rebecca, Jess, Marguerita,
Andrew, Cameron, and
my fellow fellows
for making my experience
at Radcliffe so enjoyable.
A special thanks
to Yukio Lippit,
Meg Rotzel, Joe Zane for taking
care of the art fellows, Kathy
King and Geoff Booras
from the ceramics
program for the assistance
with my technically challenging
project, and my lovely
assistant, Morgan Spalling.
Thank you everyone
who came out today.
The selection of works
I'm presenting today
are not in chronological
order and span
a period of almost 10 years.
I'm more interested in
reflecting on my work
as a constellation
of overlapping
relationships and
circular readings rather
than a linear trajectory.
There is always more to
say than I have time for,
and I hope that
there always will be.
I will cover a lot
in this lecture,
and we'll move fast
through different works,
linking them by theme,
process, and other interests.
I thought that this format would
give you a generous overview
of my practice.
I hope it works.
You tell me at the end.
My work is concerned
with circulation
at the level of the body, at
the level of global industry,
and all levels in between.
It tracks materials,
ideologies, and bodies
that travel by foot,
by car, by plane,
and by my own semantic
displacements.
Circulation and displacement
are at the core of my work
and the core of the work
that you were looking at.
"Point Zero" is a wall coated
in iron-rich soil relocated
from Brasilia, Brazil's capital.
Later, a sample of
the same soil was
turned into a custom
made silkscreen ink
and used to print
a chart of my steps
as I follow after
so many others.
"Brasilia By Foot" maps a
series of shortcuts generated
by pedestrian's
movements overlaid
on the modernist outline of
Brasilia's monumental axis.
While the satellite image shows
the accumulation of thread
lines through the grass,
the five soil ink prints
charge the number
of steps required
to traverse those
paths, establishing
a direct relationship between
the scale of the human body
and the scale of the city
designed for the car.
My work is informed
by a lifetime
of cultural dislocation
and voluntary migrations,
starting with my birth
in southern Brazil
within a community of
Italian immigrants descents,
following by growing
up in Brasilia,
Brazil's modernist-planned
capital, whose population
reflects Brazil's cultural and
ethnic diversity, attending
college in Sao Paolo, graduate
school in Los Angeles,
with many other
stops in between.
Some moves were initiated by my
parents, others by my own will,
and lately, the current
privileged mobility I
came to acquire as an artist.
I mention this almost
constant mobility
because negotiating difference,
diversity, multiplicity,
hybridisation,
and otherness have
become the places from which
I engage with art making.
I'm interested in movement as
displacement and its resulting
transformations.
This early work,
"Unmapping the World,"
tells of this
desire to emancipate
fixed ideas about places.
It is a series of
road map drawings made
by balling up blank
sheets of tracing paper
and drawing the globe
on the resulting three
dimensional surface to
then flatten them back
into their original
two-dimensional form.
This simple gesture fragments
the globe contours and presents
an ever-changing world
map configuration.
One of the first works I
made in graduate school
has also proved appreciant
of my continuing interests.
For [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE],,
or "Portuguese Balls,"
I used to sugar, a Brazilian
export and a symbol of its
colonial past and
post-colonial present,
to create casts of the
[INAUDIBLE] space in my mouth
as I formed each of
the Portuguese vowels--
ah, eh, ee, oh, ooh.
On the one hand, my language is
my identity, but on the other,
I am a foreigner
in my own tongue.
Language is a foreign
agent in my mouth,
a colonial imposition, and to
speak is to voice my otherness.
The piece was a meditation
on my personal experience
of dislocation and
an acknowledgment
of the colonial histories
that formed Brazil.
Most of the works
I've made since
continue to circle
around those topics.
Far from isolating myself in
a conventional studio routine,
my work stems from dialogue
with other disciplines
such as history, architecture,
archeology, anthropology,
even literature and
science fiction.
I research academic sources
with a non-academic approach.
I usually look for details
regarded as insignificant
in a larger context.
I am drawn to material
evidence of histories
that define a place.
I pull information from
all sorts of sources
and give equal
importance to all of it.
My goal is never
to prove a thesis,
because I never have a
thesis to start with.
My work are entry points
in intricate subjects
and never tell the whole story.
They are just a translation of
my intense mental and emotional
activity into materiality,
and yet, this coming together
tends to happen spontaneously
and organically.
So for example,
this installation,
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE],,
which is currently
on view at the
Blanton Museum of Art,
investigates the impact of
industrialization in the Amazon
region and the material culture
of the indigenous groups
in the area.
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE],,
or "Meeting of Waters,"
takes its name from the
confluence of the Negro
and upper Amazon rivers at
the port of the Brazilian city
of Manaus.
For nearly four miles
after they meet,
the black and beige waters
run parallel to each other
but did not intermix.
The Port of Manaus
serves as another type
of confluence point,
that of foreign capital
and local traditions.
Beginning in the
late 19th century,
British investment
transformed Manaus
into the center
of the rubber boom
and the most industrialized
city in Brazil.
After 1912, when the British
turned to alternative rubber
sources within their colonies,
the city became impoverished.
Today, the port again
facilitates the movement
of capital.
Following a decade
of deregulation
that began in 1957, the city
became a free trade zone
and now holds the manufacturing
plants of such companies
as Apple, Sony, LG, Coca-Cola,
Dow, Harley Davidson,
and Honda motorcycles.
The commodities made
at these factories
enter the global
market on cargo ships
that exit the Port of Manaus.
Foreign industry has
revitalized the region,
but only after bankrupting
it in the past.
Industry brings money, but it
also pollutes the landscape
and disregards local culture,
turning Manaus into one
off thousands of
production hubs worldwide
that feed a growing
appetite for more.
At the center of
the installation
is a large-scale
tapestry that depicts
the stretch of the
Amazon River that
lies between the river's
mouth in the Atlantic
Ocean and Manaus,
the exact stretch
that cargo ships traverse to
access the free trade zone.
Taking two identical
prints of the river
from a Google Earth
satellite image composite,
I cut and woven them together,
positioning the photographs
in opposite directions to mimic
the route of goods, materials,
and people.
Additionally, I've been
shredding Amazon.com boxes,
commodity culture refuse,
and using the strips
to make baskets based on
[FOREIGN] weaving techniques.
By the way, thanks
to everyone who
collaborated and
contributed with Amazon
boxes to this project.
The ubiquitous
Amazon.com box symbolized
automate mobility and has
come to represent the illusion
that goods come from nowhere.
In theory, commodity goods
produced in the Amazon forest
could travel through
the Amazon River
in order to be delivered to
our doorsteps by Amazon.com.
In [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE],,
these Amazon.com woven baskets
service as containers to display
terracotta replicas of iPhones,
computer parts, electronics,
Coca-Cola bottles, Epson ink
cartridge, motorcycle
tires, and other goods
manufactured in Manaus.
Terracotta is the material
traditionally used
by Amazonian native cultures
in ceramic production.
These replicas were
rendered hollow
by the laborious
terracotta sleep casting
and, obviously,
lack functionality.
Cracks and other imperfections
enhance their ambiguity.
They are part trash,
part archaeological finds
of our present time.
This casts actually built
on an early work of mine
"Spent," in which I fossilized
items of my domestic waste
into porcelain pieces.
The objects were all
pieces of garbage
which I dipped in porcelain
slip and subsequently fired
in a kiln.
Paper, cotton, rags,
seeds, coffee cups,
and other materials
all turned to ashes
due to the high
temperature, rendering
the original waste as
sterilized, hollow,
porcelain shells.
As this work suggests, I
favor sculptural procedures
that emphasize tactility such
as mold making, imprints,
and casting.
All of these processes
map the texture
and kept the surface and
real scale of things.
Obviously, the objects projected
look much larger than they
would be if exhibited here.
My sculptures embody materiality
at the level of the skin
to draw out the relationships
between material
cultural production,
effect, industry, consumer
society, and our bodies.
For example, these
are plaster casts
of the interior
of used sneakers.
These sculptures
merge the actual shape
of the foot with these
multinational brand signifiers
such as Adidas three stripes,
Nike's swoosh, New Balance's N,
Puma's jumping puma, et cetera.
In Brazil, young
people are killed
over their branded sneakers.
Those killings have
become a recurring topic
in the sensationalist
press, and led
to the creation of the
term [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE],,
or sneaker thief, which is
also the title of the work.
This work once
traveled to Colombia,
and when it
re-entered the US, TSA
cut up a couple of the
casts in search of cocaine.
This sculptures
now bear the marks
left by the structures and
regulations of global travel.
Out of this incident,
I made a new piece,
"Work Damaged by
Customs During Search
for Cocaine Upon Re-Entry to the
United States from Colombia."
The damaged sneaker casts
rest on top of shipping crates
that I rebuilt from the wood
used in the original shipment.
Still considering similar
sculptural procedures
while we are engaging with
commodities' histories,
we can look at this other work,
"Transplanted, VW Brasilia"--
a skin-like, deflated,
natural latex imprint
of a Volkswagen Brasilia.
The VW Brasilia was
the first VW model
entirely designed and
manufactured by Volkswagen
in Brazil.
It was named after
the city of Brasilia
because Brasilia's urban plan
emphasizes the role of the car,
and in Brazil, the
VW Brasilia soon
became a national design icon.
The use of latex is
significant because of the way
latex industry is bound
up in Brazil's history
and economy, the car
industry, and therefore
the city of Brasilia.
Latex is harvested
from the rubber
tree, hevea brasiliensis,
which is native to the Amazon.
In the mid-19th century,
huge amounts of latex
were being exported from Brazil.
Then in 1876, the British
explorer Henry Wickham
smuggled seeds from the rubber
treating center in Brazil
and took them back
to the Kew Gardens
in London, where they were
soon sent to Malaysia,
a British territory.
Rubber plantations in Malaysia
doomed the Amazonian rubber
boom and enabled the
British to have a world
monopoly on rubber production.
I then display them along
with this young rubber tree
on loan from Pasadena's
Huntington Botanical Gardens
herb garden.
The car used for
the latex imprint
in "Transplanted
Brasilia" is the same car
I used as a central piece in
the installation, "Brasilia
Carpools and Other Modernities"
in which I brought this 1973
Volkswagen hatchback
from the city of Brasilia
to Santa Monica, California,
fully loaded with full cleaning
equipment in order to assist
with the 1964 modernist streak
house swimming pool
maintenance routine.
Brasilia's architect,
Oscar Niemeyer Meyer,
designed this house
in Santa Monica
at the same time he
was designing Brasilia,
but he never visited the beauty.
His communist
affiliations prevented him
from entering the US.
The installation connected
the two locations
of Niemeyer work, which are also
the two cities that most shaped
my life.
The photos that you are seeing
are from the meeting in LA
at the Hammer Museum in
2014, and I won't have time
to show the video--
there is a video component
to the installation--
and the interesting aspect of
it is that the camera is always
attached to the
car, so the image
has a lot of
vibration and noise.
It's not the
depiction of the city
that you are used to with
the well-composed modernist
photographs or
images of the city.
It's very noisy, and your eyes
on line is always a little
tilted, and it's
intercepted with images
of the house in Los Angeles.
I grew up in Brasilia,
and I keep circling back
to create works about the city.
As a child, I was simultaneously
fascinated and shocked
by Oscar Niemeyer's buildings
because they seemed more
like monumental abstract
sculptures than buildings.
And as Judy mentioned,
I have an extensive body
of work on Brasilia,
but unfortunately, I
won't be able to show much of
that today, or I chose not to.
I'm showing more in the works
related to the Amazon region.
That's what I'm doing now.
As a teenager, I recall
walking at night on vast areas
off undeveloped land to get
to the next super square,
residential areas within
Brasilia's pilot plan.
The city, still under
construction in some areas,
had a feeling of unrestrained
freedom and vacancy.
Later, I intellectualized
the place Brasilia
holds symbolically
and historically
in the country's dominant
narrative with all
its complexities
and contradictions.
My experience of
Brasilia also informed
the way I approach architecture
as a device for thinking.
Niemeyer's design for
Brasilia is one example.
Another is two small
rubber plantation villages
in the Amazon jungle,
viewed by Ford Motor
Company in the late 1920s and
1930s, Fordlandia and Belterra.
The model for this
worker's house,
oddly, was New England
style Cape Cod cottages,
even though the workers would be
living in the tropical forest.
At about the same time, Ford
built the town of Alberta
in Michigan's Upper Peninsula.
At the time, wood is still used
in the making of automobiles,
and Alberta was conceived
as a model sawmill
town for lumber production.
The work I created about
this equivalent architecture
was titled "Streamlined--
Belterra, Amazonia,
Alberta, Michigan"--
and unfolded as a two channel
video and eight channel sound
installation in which I created
a mirror-like situation between
Belterra, Ford's second rubber
plantation village along
the Tapajos River in
the Amazon forest,
and Alberta in Michigan.
Each channel of the
video is projected
onto one side of a freestanding
wall, Belterra on one side,
Alberta on the other, but the
framing, camera movements,
pace, and additives
are synchronized.
One replicates the other, but
cannot be seen simultaneously,
which causes a sensation of an
episode of deja vu when passing
from one side of the
freestanding wall to the other.
Oh, just-- Just
play a few minutes.
Obviously, the video is
never shown like this.
This is just for
lecture purpose.
You wouldn't be seeing the
images next to each other.
The video begins with close-ups
of shared architecture features
suggesting that the subjects
of the two videos are the same,
and then the shots get
broader, slowly revealing
that the surrounding
environments are
very different from each other.
Although the towns are
formally equivalent,
difference is
established through views
of the landscape, architectural
adaptations, and snapshots
of each town's daily rhythm.
[WHISTLE]
- The sound is a factory
whistle that is [INAUDIBLE] in--
[TRAFFIC NOISE]
- In Belterra, the town
in the Amazon, but now
it's aligned with school time.
They think that that's part
of the identity of the place.
The installation presents
an uncanny situation
that makes the familiar
foreign, and vise versa.
[ROOSTER CROWING]
- OK, I will jump a little.
Kind of destroying
my own work, but--
So you have images of--
as I said, it's
like the narrative
is one day in the
life of these towns,
and there is still some rubber
tappers that work independently
in Alberta and in Michigan.
The town is part of the
Michigan Tech University,
so you have students
doing field work
and living there for a semester.
So, and then it ends
with people exercising,
and what I want to show this.
So one thing-- these benches
here, I made replicas of them,
and those are the benches
that are in the installation,
and this is the obviously
spontaneous addition
to the planned city.
It's not part of the original
plan, but for some reason,
most of the houses have these
benches facing to each other,
and that's the place
where people socialize
at the end of the day.
In addition to the
videos, I did this series
of 14 photographs that are
called "When Two Places Look
Alike," and they are part of
the same body of the work.
So I created a typological
study of the workers houses
by juxtaposing fragments
of them with cut
out cards that travel with
me across the hemisphere
to each location.
By using my hand
to hold the cards,
I insert myself as a
connector of these two
locations, these two places--
sorry-- these two physically
distant places that share
a historical background.
The current
inhabitants of Alberta
are totally unaware
that there is
this other town in South
America that looks just
like their town and vise versa.
While Western industry exported
traditional New England
architecture style
to the Amazon region,
quintessential American
architect Frank Lloyd Wright
incorporated Mayan features such
as the textile concrete block
system in some of his
residential buildings
built in Los Angeles
in the early 1900s.
The video, "Ch'u Mayaa," was
filmed at one of these houses,
the Hollyhock House, which was
designed for the feminist oil
heiress, Aline Barnsdall, who
was also a patron of the arts
and later donated the
house to the city.
This was the piece that
I received the commission
for from the city of LA for
a Geddes Foundation Pacific
Standard Time LA LA.
To my response to the overlooked
influence of Mayan architecture
on Wright's work by
reappropriating the building
as a temple and
imbuing it with a dance
performance based on
gestures and postures
found in ancient Mayan
pottery and murals.
Through the movement
of a female performer,
the house is
resignified, or claimed,
as belonging to the
pre-Columbian Mesoamerican
architecture lineage.
The title, translated
"Maya Blue"
from K'iche', one of the Mayan
languages spoken in LA today,
refers to the ancient azure
pigment found in Mayan pottery
and murals, well known for being
remarkably weather resistant
and enduring the
passage of time.
So these are just--
I don't expect you
to read all of this,
but it's just to show a
little bit of the reference
of my research for creating
a catalog of movements,
and I will play a
little bit of the video.
[FLUTE PLAYING]
[BIRD CHIRPING]
- I will jump again.
Unfortunately, I can play
the whole thing, so--
I'm going to go a few sections.
[WIND WHISTLING]
- The very end.
Sorry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HEART BEATING]
[THUNDER]
[WIND WHISTLING]
[GLASS BREAKING]
- OK, following my research on
the Hollyhock House-- oh no--
I see this piece very much in
dialogue with my sculptures,
which frequently suggest
the presence of a body
and trace history
through gesture
Like the video about
Belterra and Alberta,
this piece is an
attempt to excavate
the unacknowledged
narratives contained
in modernist buildings.
Following my research
on the Hollyhock House,
I became more and more
interested in the 1920s
architectural trend of
Mayan revival buildings
in the US, which
co-opted the architecture
and iconography of pre-Columbian
Mesoamerican cultures.
The style was popular
in Los Angeles,
so I decided to focus on the
Mayan Theater, a Landmark Grand
Cinema palace built during the
golden age of the movie-going.
The interior design was done
by Mexican sculptor Francisco
Cornejo, whose work specialized
in Maya and Aztec themes.
I researched his sources--
Quirigua and Piedras Negras
in Guatemala and Yaxchilan
in the Yucatan in Mexico--
and became fascinated
by the sophistication
of ancient Mayan
architecture in regards
to its performative quality
and relationship to the body.
So I decided to make
a series of sculptures
that would make
the beauty embody
those qualities sculpturally.
I made imprints of the reliefs
that decorate the Mayan Theater
doors and walls with thick
swatches of silicone.
The skin-like fragments
of architecture
became elements of
assemblage of sculptures
and were joined with
terracotta plaster casts
of hands and feet locked
in gestures sourced
from the original
archaeological sites,
as well as bits of faux
Jaguar fur, quetzal feather,
and serpent skin.
I also tried to
bring a little bit
of the information about
the source material
through the titles.
So, for instance,
in this work, which
was "Yaxchilan Lintel
25 Feather Serpent,"
I made an imprint of one
panel of an exit door that
had an engraved based
on that specific lintel,
more precisely the section
with the feather serpent,
a Mayan supernatural entity,
and then the sculpture
unfolded with relationships
with the body and the space.
Another one, "Ha' Ki'n Xook--
From Piedras Negras
to Hill Street,"
tells you the name
of Piedras Negras
ruler six, who was recreated
in the entrance hall
doorway of the theater on
Hill Street in downtown LA.
A two-headed serpent in the
arms of human beings, or ticket
window, is also very descriptive
of the imagery appropriated
and used around
the ticket window.
And here you have just some--
I don't expect you
to read that, again.
It's just some indication
of my research.
"The Heel Up in the Leg Cast
to Make the Building Dance"--
this one is indicative
that a figure would
be dancing in Mayan paintings
applied to vessels and murals,
so the whole body
could be still.
If a figure has
the heel up, that
would mean that that
figure would be dancing,
and the maize god, which
is painted on this plate,
is usually portrayed
dancing with the heel up.
"A Cycle of Time We
Don't Understand--
Reverse, Invented,
and Rearranged"
has a more elusive title that
relates to the glyphs created
for the theater's entrance
floor that are mostly
inspired by Calendrical glyphs.
Mayan hieroglyphs would
never be placed on the floor,
so I placed the swatches
of silicone on the wall,
as it could have appeared
in a Mayan interior, usually
around the borders of a
metalogical or historical
scene.
Another detail
important to point out
is the repetition of the word
faux in the material list--
faux terracotta dyed
plaster, jaguar faux fur,
quetzal faux feather, died
rooster feather, faux serpent
skin, and lastly,
synthetic hair.
The insistence in
faux and synthetic
was a way to suggest that
all the imagery contained
on the silicone
imprints is also false.
My intention was to restore
to the Mayan theater
the immanence of
its source material
while simultaneously
accentuating its design
as a product of mimesis.
OK, I will end just
saying a few words of what
I am looking at right now.
So, what I'm working
on at the moment
is the very early stages
of a new installation that
will further consider ecology
and Amazonian native people's
static reduction
in the relationship
to contemporary
commodity culture.
The project will speculate on
a post-apocalyptic materiality
that follows the Earth's
ecological collapse.
What will remain when the Earth
as we know it is destroyed?
In developing the
work, I've been
inspired by Octavia E. Butler's
science fiction trilogy
Lilith's Blood from 1989.
For those of you who
don't know this book,
I would explain very briefly--
in Lilith's Blood,
the human race
saves itself from
extinction by partnering
with an alien
species, the Oankali.
The Oankali's world is
made of living things,
and that's what I'm interested--
living things.
There space ship is
structured like a rainforest
and is fueled by food scraps.
Their vehicles are
Oankali-made animals
that respond telepathically.
Their walls open
and close according
to Oankali biochemistry.
Eventually, the Amazon
Forest becomes the side
of origin for a new civilization
of Oankali-human human hybrids.
In Butler's
configuration, the Amazon
is a site of second possibility,
and yet finite resources.
I intended this new
body of work to inhabit
an imaginary space of
post-Oankali-human occupation
of Earth.
My hope is to
create objects that
teeter between the
prehistoric and futuristic--
objects that seem ruins
of a world yet to come.
I've been conducting research
at the Peabody Museum's
Amazonian [INAUDIBLE]
ceramics collection,
and you see two examples here.
Especially there
are clay Monachinis
that were at the
work-in-process exhibition
that we had in January
here at the Radcliffe,
and the funerary urns.
I'm also expanding on my
understanding of Amazonian
[FOREIGN],, basket
weave and practices,
and indigenous Amazon
cosmology in general.
I'm very interested in the
religious significance of trees
and sacred animals, and
how those images are still
used in Amazonian native
static traditions today.
So I will leave it here.
Thank you.